Easy writing makes for hard reading. So
if you want readers to breeze through
your next essay and actually remember
what you write, then you need to
understand what happens in their mind as
they read. Reading is a fantastically
complex task. But in my 10 years of
teaching writing from the reader's
perspective, I've narrowed it down to
four core writing hacks that are
designed to work with your reader's
memory. So, in this video, I'm going to
show you how to transition between ideas
smoothly without losing your reader. How
to write in visual cinematic style
without overwhelming your reader with
details. And how to keep your story
moving forward without littering your
text with boring signposts. By the end
of this video, you'll be able to give
your writing that effortless feeling of
flow that keeps your readers glued to
the page because you'll know exactly
what their brain needs at each moment of
the reading process. And by the way, if
you're new here, my name is Will. I'm an
English professor in South Korea and I
help non-fiction writers write well. So,
if you want to learn about the art and
science of expert writing, be sure to
grab my free newsletter, Writer Science.
link is down below the like button. What
happens when we read? Well, when you
read a single phrase like scattered
breadcrumbs, your brain decodes abstract
symbols into a vivid mental image. You
decode the text and you encode meaning,
but that meaning creates a problem for
your reader because they need to hang on
to it while they go about decoding the
other meanings in the sentence. For
example, watch what happens when you
read this sentence. Scattered
breadcrumbs disappeared into the beaks
of sparrows that hopped across the park
bench and fluttered down to the gravel
path below. So, what happened here?
Well, as you move through this sentence
in time from left to right, the image
that's forming in your mind isn't really
clear. It's kind of diffuse and static
at first. First, we get these
disembodied breadcrumbs like the smile
of a cheshier cat. They're just hanging
there in the ether, right? They
disappear as in they vanish. Oh, no.
They disappear into the beaks of
sparrows. Oh, there are sparrows there.
All right. So, where did those sparrows
come from? Ah, they had hopped across
the park bench. And where's that? Oh,
it's along the gravel path, which turns
out to be below our perspective. So, you
see the way that works, you only find
out where you, the reader, are standing
in space at the end of the sentence. The
way the sentence is written, it gives
the particulars first and then the
context. So, if the writer is like a
cinematographer, then this shot is like
a wide cinematic tilt-down zoom out
effect. So, how would you change this
sentence to produce the reverse effect?
Well, you could write something like
this. On the gravel path below, sparrows
hopped across the park bench to eat the
scattered breadcrumbs. Written like
this, and you move from wide to close,
beginning with context and ending with
the focus of the scene. But the point
here isn't to say that one sentence is
better than the other. It's more to show
that both of these effects are possible
because of the way that reading works.
You don't read a whole sentence all at
once. You move from left to right, word
by word, building up meaning as you go.
And as you move through these words and
images, decoding them all, your brain
has to juggle all these pieces that
you've encoded until the sentence makes
sense, which can actually be pretty
tricky because now we know that your
short-term memory can really only hold
three or four things at once. We used to
think it was seven and eight, but now we
know that it's more like three to four,
and that's it. So, how do you read
entire paragraphs without your brain
exploding? Well, your brain uses a
pretty clever trick called chunking. So,
instead of remembering every single word
and every single meaning that you
encode, it compresses everything into a
mental briefcase. After each sentence,
your brain packs only the essential
information and carries them forward
into the next sentence. So, what exactly
goes into that briefcase? Well, I'm glad
you asked. There are four things that go
into your reader's mental briefcase. And
if you learn how to control them, then
you'll be able to create an easy reading
experience. And the first thing that
comes in that mental briefcase might
surprise you. You're actually going to
find it in the last few words of the
sentence. because the end of your
sentence lingers in the reader's mind,
kind of like the impression that you
leave when you run your hand over a body
of water. And so that impression is
hanging there as your reader starts the
next sentence. So if you can begin the
next sentence on a similar note to the
one which is still hanging in their
short-term memory, then you create a
great kind of relay race effect where
the end of one sentence passes off the
baton to the beginning of the next one.
So let me show you how this works in
practice. At noon in the crowded
cafeteria buzzing with conversation,
Sarah sat across from her mother. The
two women staring at their untouched
coffee avoided the topic that they'd
come to discuss. You see the connection
between these two sentences? Sarah and
her mother becomes the two women. So the
end of the first sentence echoes into
the start of the second one. Like the
two sentences are shaking hands with
each other. Now the second thing in your
reader's briefcase is called the topic,
which is who or what your sentence is
telling a story about. And the topic is
a very important concept to understand
because it goes against the grain of a
lot of writing advice. Something I see
thrown around a lot on writing YouTube
and in these advice forums is that
people say you need to vary your
sentences, right? If you repeat
yourself, then it just gets boring. You
say, "I'm monotonous." But this couldn't
be further from the truth. Monotony and
repetition helps your readers keep track
of elements as you develop them across
sentences and paragraphs. And one of the
great places to have repetition is in
the topic position. So just imagine that
you're at a party and you're having a
conversation with your friend Jessica
about her new business. Okay? So, you're
bandandying back and forth about this
new business and then your friend Fred
walks in and says, "Uh, whoa, the
weather's been kind of crazy lately."
Well, Fred, you're being an idiot. Why?
Because that the weather has nothing to
do with the topic of conversation, which
is Jessica's business. And that's kind
of obvious in social situations. But
what I'm trying to help you see is that
that's exactly what you're doing when
you vary the topics in your sentences
without real reason. Like your reader's
mind is kind of like a camera following
a main character. They assume because
they read from left to right, they
assume that whatever shows up at the
start of the sentence is the thing that
the sentence tells a story about. So
when you vary that without much reason,
well, it's kind of like Fred walking in
and suddenly talking about the weather.
It's like there's nothing wrong with his
sentence, but it doesn't track to the
topic that's being developed here. So
let's take a look at an example. David
pushed through the office door exhausted
from the allnight writing session. Now,
when you read that from left to right,
you implicitly assume that David is the
topic of the sentence. And so the way
this sentence is written has your brain
lock on to David. He's the topic. He's
the star of the show and he's the one
who's doing the action, which is
pushing. So the camera in your reader's
mind follows him, expecting him to
appear in the next sentence. And that
expectation on the part of the reader
was set by the way the sentence was
written. They're expecting David to show
up in the next sentence. But what if the
next sentence said the printer was out
of paper again? Well, that's jarring.
But if you write, he headed straight for
the coffee machine. Well, now that flows
naturally because readers consider
whatever appears first in the sentence
to be the star of the show. That's the
thing that the sentence tells a story
about. and they can more easily chunk
information about a topic when a group
of sentences in a paragraph or any given
section maintain focus on a consistent
topic. Now, this doesn't mean that you
need to repeat the same word over again.
You could easily swap out David with he
or the writer, for instance. It just
means that you shouldn't vary the start
of your sentences just for the sake of
variety because this consistency in
topics makes reading easy. And the third
thing that's in your reader's briefcase
is probably the most powerful and these
are sensory impressions that bring your
words to life. So, close your eyes and
think of your grandmother's kitchen.
I'll bet that you don't just see it. You
actually smell something like cookies
baking or Thanksgiving dinner. You can
feel the warmth or a certain ambiance in
the room. Maybe you can hear the creek
of a floorboard that you would walk over
when you walked through the door. This
is the power of sensory memory. It's not
just visual. It's a full experience
compressed into a single mental file.
And you give your reader these full
experiences when you write with concrete
sensory language. So let me show you the
difference. Compare these two sentences.
First, delivery of the package to the
customer's door occurred. Now just pause
to think about the image that formed in
your mind as you read that. Now contrast
it with this. The package was delivered
to the customer's door. Now if you ask
me, the first one gives you nothing to
hold on to. But with the second one, you
can actually see the package in motion.
And in my mind, the really interesting
thing is that not only do I see all the
elements that are articulated in that
sentence, but there's also a lot of
added context. You know, I can see the
apartment building in which the door is
and maybe the hallway and the hands of
the delivery driver dropping off the
package. When you write with concrete
imagery, your brain fills in a lot of
the missing context just through its
association with those concrete images.
And I think the reason that this extra
context and details don't appear with
the first one is that it's written not
with these concrete sensory objects, but
with these abstract concepts. Right?
Delivery. That's a noun that's being
used to represent an important action.
So, one of them is concrete, the other
one is abstract. And the more you write
with concrete words, the easier it is
for readers to see the situation you
describe. Now, the fourth and final
thing in your reader's mental briefcase
is expectations. The promise that you
make which pulls them forward. And now I
call them expectations and not cliffhers
because we normally think of cliffhers
as the moments of suspense that bridge
episodes in a series. You can set reader
expectations at the micro level as well.
So watch how this works at the sentence
level. Sarah discovered something
shocking in her mother's attic. Now I
don't know about you, but when I read a
sentence like that, my brain
automatically needs to know what she
found. I'm already launched into the
next sentence. The word shocking sets an
expectation and you as the reader carry
that expectation forward in your
briefcase as you go searching for the
payoff. You're hooked. But that word is
a little cliche and I really mean it
here. Like hooking a fish. The reader is
now pulled forward through the text by
the energy generated in this
expectation. And all good writing runs
on this kind of an engine, setting
expectations in one sentence and then
paying it off at strategic moments
later. The reading brain is in pursuit.
It uses the stuff of the past to
anticipate the future. So pay attention
to where you set expectations and where
you pay them off. But now that we
understand how memory works in your
reader's mind, I think the real question
is how can we use this to our advantage?
Easy. with these four writing hacks.
First, put emphasis worthy information
at the end of the sentence in the stress
position. Second, put main characters at
the start of the sentence in the topic
position. Third, ground abstract
concepts in concrete images. And fourth,
manage reader expectations carefully
because memory is only one aspect of
reader psychology. And if you really
want your ideas to jump off the page and
into the mind of the reader, then you
need to watch this video next because
it's going to show you four more writing
hacks that readers love. So, be sure to
go check it out.